ils étaient six ans pour aïda est sûrs
en dot ils sont aujourd'hui dix mille à
bercy dix mille petits chanteurs réunis
pour leur 22e congrès international à
cette occasion le compositeur marcel
landowski a écrit un champ pour la paix
dans les paroles ont été inspiré d'un
poème de jean paul ii cette rencontre de
jeunes qui ont déjà chanté ce matin sur
le parvis de l'hôtel de ville va se
poursuivre jusqu'au 7 juillet marie
claire gauthier assisté cet après midi à
une dernière répétition à bercy c'est le
père mallié qui donna avec la
manécanterie des petits chanteurs à la
croix de bois un souffle nouveau à la
vie des chorales voilà 22 ans qu'elle se
réunisse aux quatre coins de l'europe
aujourd'hui et sont venus à 10000 la
congrès international et il répété cet
après midi s'installant progressivement
sur les gradins rouge de bercy pour
interpréter toutes langues confondues
une oeuvre du compositeur
marcel landowski sont bp spécialement
composé pour cette occasion sur des
poèmes du pape jean paul ii
le début je me suis dit c'est pas
possible tu me dis mais c'est vrai
qu'elle a dû bloquer la musique
les actus la musique depuis dont 6 ou 10
mois dans les toutes les parties du
monde
ils ont travaillé non peu enfreint et
pour la première fois hier soir j'ai
commencé à les faire un peu travaillé et
maintenant pour cette répétition et
demain dans la prochaine édition qui
sera générale le bay vont tous chanté en
choeur ce refrain qu'elle est amoureuse
ici qu'une telle
c'est d'être ensemble nous et comme il
ya près de cent mètres entre l'
orchestre les coeurs parisien qui chante
et qui enregistrait même le disque déjà
et puis ceux qui seront au double de cet
immense vaisseau que représente bercy et
bien pour que avec le temps dure le
temps de la vitesse du son je me semble
d'un connaisseur maître deleu provenir
bien un décalage qui est extrêmement
difficile a complaisamment le volet
faire des choses exceptionnelles cette
année parce que d'avoir besoin de la
parrine sont très chauvin paris c'est
quand même la ville lumière paris attire
toujours le monde est franche et à la
musique que paris ne pouvait pas faire
un petit congrès et ensuite ceux qui
avaient l'habitude des convives du
chanteur se souvenait que oui on faisait
des choses intéressantes mais enfin
heureusement qu'ils avaient la
visibilité s'est pas toujours très
enthousiasmant alors on se dit on a des
jeunes c'est l'année de la jeunesse
il faut qu'on s'amuse ensemble qu'on ait
de la loi ensemble ça se voit qu'on est
heureux de vivre ensemble et en suisse
elle est de la musique et il faut en
faire faire de la vraie musique est ce
que ça représente de chanter ensemble
cet été noté cru les corréziens un
cerveau est un petit peu
hamon
zuma
de foyen du chantage angers puis
d'autres
et jean-louis moi j'étais porté par les
par le texte
du pape qui est un texte a quitté eux
je fais toujours écrire avec mon coeur
je sais que le pack les creepers
totalement avec son coeur maintenant
aces réussis je n'en sais rien l'avenir
le dira
oh